i also i'm going to let the camera know
that if needed i will be the best wing
woman
i went to a pickup artist boot camp i
know what you're thinking what is a
pickup artist boot camp and why on earth
was i a girl there why as a female would
i want to attend a pickup artist for how
to pick up women first of all i am not
gay i am not
men only what is pick up artistry and
where did it come from when i first
googled pickup artist the definition
that came up was a person who is skilled
at striking up conversations in order to
attract a sexual partner as a female it
blows my mind that there is an entire
community dedicated to understanding
women are we that special dating is much
harder for men than you might think the
man of sphere has mixed opinions on
pickup some people say the guys are
creeped some people say that it's
helpful and some people say that it's a
waste of time i'm nosy so i decided i'm
gonna go check it out the first step was
finding a pickup artist that seemed
credible i came across john anthony
lifestyle's youtube channel and you
could not deny the man
seem to know how to get laid he lives
with three brazilian smoke shows in a
mansion in brazil he claims to have
slept with over a thousand women and
honestly he's provided more evidence of
that claim than anyone else in the
pickup community so i reached out to him
had him on my channel pitched the idea
and he invited me to his boot camp he
said that i could bring any guy to this
boot camp to test it out and we can give
a full review afterwards i met a guy
through mutual friends that was familiar
with pickup and was interested in coming
he was on the more experienced end with
women but i figured if he was willing to
be on camera and review his experience
that was a win for me
all right guys
i would bust it as hell
because i literally got on a red eye
this morning at the crack of dawn and
i'm so tired
so there's a whole
casino right in the lobby guys i'm cheap
i don't even like gambling this is what
100 a night and gets you in vegas so i'm
pretty close to the strip like i mean
this isn't like a great hotel
literally dirt on the floor i'm so
nervous i'm so nervous about this i
don't know if it's going to be weird
but it's going to be interesting for
sure
ryan's familiar with pickup so he's
actually going to be able to give you
guys a decent review on if this is
helpful or not helpful it's so easy for
girls to get guys you don't really think
about this stuff no not really but
so i'm ryan bergman and yeah we're out
here to check it out give a good review
or a good understanding as to what they
teach what are your impressions so far
as far as the group of guys that we're
going with it seems kind of like the
typical culture where the people that go
to these kind of boot camps they're
typically i almost feel like obsessed is
like a little bit strong but they are
definitely like fixated on techniques
and gimmicks and tricks to try and just
pull girls when you were like studying
this stuff were you obsessed with it or
no i actually didn't get my first kiss
till i was 21 i'm 26 now my best friend
actually introduced me to it a little
bit and then i started watching some of
the videos and i started learning some
of the tricks but the real
value in it is actually learning to
convert those tricks into something part
of your personality one of the typical
ones that i would see a lot is where
when you first walk up to a girl you
kind of stick out your hand
and then to meet them they go for a
little shake and then you'll take their
hand and just do a little twirl oh
that's so
so
that i feel like that does work in
certain circumstances but if you're
doing that to every girl then it is then
it's not really you being yourself it's
easy for girls to sleep with men yeah
but there's definitely like a harder
time for them to get relationships i
feel like every girl has like five guy
friends ish in the friend zone oh
definitely that like she could date if
she wanted to yes yeah
okay guys so we are going to keep you
updated throughout the night yeah and
we're going to tell you if this stuff is
legit or if it's not you ready let's get
it we're going to meet the guys i think
i'm going to make a lot of friends to be
honest i'm a chit chatter i'm a friendly
person what do you think you think
you'll make friends tonight i don't know
i'll be honest i'm a little skeptical
oh it's this one
[Music]
we're looking for houston we're a part
of the group chat bringing us bringing
us bring it in
i'm uh i'm super stoked for another
weekend in vegas i just like this is the
stuff like that makes life like
beautiful these are
stuff you look back on and be like i'm
super grateful that i went to vegas that
weekend the friendships you'll make here
with the guys around you with the
coaches and this is stuff that like
throughout my life uh the my best
friends i've ever had have been guys
that i've met like that new game for
some reason
something about game just brings people
together in a way that's just like
unforgettable uh yeah first thing i want
to talk about
uh is just effort
i do not want anybody
to not have success tonight or this
weekend because of lack of effort that's
something that you can control that's in
your control the amount of people you
talk to girls you approach effort that
you put forth
that's something that's within your
control you cannot control if a girl
likes you or
if a group's gonna accept you or if the
friends like there's just so many
changing moving variables in game but
one thing that you can control is your
effort that you put in
so the beginning
first like two minutes three minutes
five minutes
has to be very calm it's it's like think
of it as like landing an airplane it's
like just first you have to land before
you start doing all this crazy [ __ ]
it's gonna be soft and subtle it's like
non-aggressive no pressure it's very
chill right
once you get there
and then she's like comfortable with you
okay because like he's like a chill
normal guy he's not needy he's not
aggressive he's not drunk or sloppier on
drugs once you kind of get to that point
then go for it bring out all the game
moves that you guys have ever learned
every bit of it whatever you want it
whatever you've learned in the past that
worked out for you go for it but a lot
of guys [ __ ] this up because they're
going for these like hail marys in the
first 30 seconds
and she's like it's [ __ ] weird i
don't know what that is so there's this
concept it's called a hot girl summer
have you ever heard of it
this is
it's
memorial day weekend right i thought
it's labor day is it labor day what are
they called slavery okay this is like
the end of summer the end of what summer
okay so i just want you guys to realize
it's like it's like full permission zero
judgment
we've been on lockdown we've been
captured in this like [ __ ] prison
cell for like two years or some [ __ ]
like this is the year that so many girls
like they're out to do their thing zero
judgment um and they're just they want
to have fun and enjoy
their summer and tonight just happens to
be the last night of summer i just feel
like the odds are very much in our favor
if needed i will be the best wing woman
um
one time in college
my friend joe wanted to hook up with
this girl right
me i took one for the team
i told her that joe was my brother
there is nothing better than a sister
brother card i know you guys think i'm
crazy but the girls they get the social
rapport being like he just wants to find
someone
it works like a charm
what opener did you just use how did
that go
um i used hey can i be honest and then
she was like yeah of course i was like
you make that dress look so dope
did it work
i mean we started talking but then but
then she said i'm gay i was like prove
it and then she kissed her girlfriend
[Music]
everybody's trying to aim for your spot
but can't nobody
[Music]
because that's what they teach right
how'd it go
went great i got a girl's number we
spoke to french
so far best game here
i told her i love her in french
he said them
[Music]
there's a few guys that i'm a little bit
surprised about they aren't quite the
same personality that i thought they
would be i thought these guys would be
all out like direct approach as they
call it yeah and um
to where it's like
hey i'm ryan like
yeah that kind of energy but there's a
few guys that it sounds like they got a
similar
game to what i do where it's just like
yo
i'm just [ __ ] ryan what the [ __ ] is
up i on the other hand i'm having a
great time oh i'm having a great time
don't don't get me wrong
i was like way too tired to give an
update at the end of the night like i
like wanted to fall asleep um i wish i
could better video things but like
security for some reason does not like
you videotaping strangers
uh i think like mostly from what i saw
it's like a confidence
thing you can't hear in a club so the
biggest thing that i noticed was like
the coaches um or like telling guys and
giving them the confidence to like go up
to girls i didn't understand like how
bad it is out there for guys like oh my
god you feel approached so many times
just to get anything like that's crazy
to me okay guys it's day two we're going
to a pool party today we made it to the
pool place
i'm ready ready to party
[Music]
i'm ready
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right be in my vlog
[Music]
yeah
the vibes in the interaction like little
subtle things like a girl yesterday she
like sits there and i'm like is your
hair really i'm like let me feel it hold
on i'm like feeling back to phil she has
these little things for hair extensions
something i made a comment about polymer
she said you can pull it later i'm like
hey like don't say stuff like that you
don't know what that does to a man's
brain you can't tell me stuff like that
and then she wants to do it more right
like little comments and again like you
just kind of go back to just being chill
and like downplaying her little slight
attempts to like hit on you you kind of
downplay me like so it makes her kind of
want to do it like so there's a lot of
things that build tension again but and
again negative like negative emotions
positive negative injecting things that
like would be opposite of trying to get
her like trying to not get her almost
like pushing away type of vibe
okay
it goes uh
it's like oh you smell really good oh
thank you you must have washed today you
see what i mean
i'm throwing i'm throwing one out there
you don't realize that you are the
[ __ ] prize
like they they want it to work
but when a guy doesn't trust himself and
doesn't see his value
she doesn't see it either
the first thing i do when i open a set
and i know they've got friends oh who'd
you come with and i introduced myself to
a friend right so now i'm friends with
their friend and i'm kind of part of the
group so i'm being proactive
eliminating that obstacle and she's
going to give me her back so be
proactive right who your friends right
and then continue with your game
how are we feeling about this clubbing
experience excited are you do you prefer
day game or night game
um so i've so far only done day game but
i think i'm gonna prefer night game just
because of the high volume and the
traffic and like you can get a lot more
and people are just waiting to be more
social like they're open to be more
social yeah it's like why they can't
it's exactly yeah exactly they came to
meet someone
i must have come in to help get girls
i personally have never been to this
club before i thought i have i was told
i needed to have a dress code which i've
never been to a club with a dresser
before
i'm ready to shimmy i'm not gonna lie i
got i got one dance move
it's the shimmy and i'm ready
[Music]
i don't think it's going badly
i still think they're a little bit
they're holding back it's a five line
though because if a guy gets like
too touchy and like such i know
[Music]
why do you think
um
they're doing well and what do you think
they're not doing well
they need to be a little bit more
physical like they're kind of
they should be a little bit more
aggressive
like touching the girls like
yeah
we did the whole club thing
i don't think anyone hold except the
coaches it's funny because once you
realize okay once you
once you realize what's like how to put
it like you understand and approach you
can like spot it out there's guys from
like a different pickup group that like
approached me after but i i saw them go
away
here's some mistakes i think that i see
people make they tell you to ask for a
kiss i don't i don't agree with that i
think the idea is like if you ask enough
girls like someone will say yes
it just comes off weak to me i like to
be club that was a very good place um
there was definitely like
a lot of people open to being
talked to so
i said i don't like the line can i kiss
you
i think if someone asked you that within
like uh like 20 minutes this place is
for it there's places for it so
consensus is key and if you're worried
that's when you should ask because you
can't go wrong with asking i literally
think you can go wrong with faster like
it would just ruin my vibe okay yeah
you can't because it also saves you a
lot of maybe embarrassment like it's
still goofy to ask so say like last
night i had i had a girl who was very
into me and
before i went for the kiss she had like
given me a little bit of her lip gloss
lips are chapped
and she kind of was really applying and
i was like yo could i maybe use some of
that and so like she gave me some let it
i just let it ride and then later on i
was like yo i could use some more lip
gloss as she was reapplying
and so she got done reapplying and then
like i leaned in for the kisses
what up guys we are in a taxi and i
wanted to get ryan's take on the night
last night some of the good stuff is
like they are trying to like push it's
good to kind of have a driving force
especially when
you ever approach anxiety and so like
you can try to talk to a lady and you're
a little bit nervous
having someone just to be able to say yo
there's a cute girl go talk to her it
takes away
just some of the
hesitants that you might have did they
give you guys like openers
oh really that was an interesting thing
they like they kind of talked to it and
talked about it and oftentimes they were
sending me into the into like an
approach with
one of the newer guys and because of
some of these guys i'm so scared
like my interaction would go well but
then the two friends would kind of make
eye contact and they'd just be like well
the one guy like all the girls that were
interested in him he was like oh they're
like like he thought they were too like
unattractive to like that's what the
short guy was telling the coach why do
you think nobody has taken anyone some
people are
just misjudging the situation um the
first night was a lot of college bills
and so you get a lot of social pressure
because
it's very hard for a lot of you guys to
actually talk to the group they're so
focused on the individual that you don't
get like the social approval from their
friend you got to be able to like vibe
with everybody
who do you think dating is harder for
men or women
[Music]
yeah so
i think it's harder what do you think is
the biggest mistake that like girls make
trying to change a man
and when they create what it is that
they created yeah they don't like it
anymore yeah that's true you're gonna
end up walking away do you think women
have too high of standards
some do some
do you think some women are delusional
yes
yes
you've had major conversations like this
happening no i think those girls are
usual to be honest but i also think
there's like
a shortage of houseboats too yeah we
scared the married women because they
delusionally yeah you you build
something with them and then they just
went out yeah and they leave and now you
just excuse my language
do you think that um girls if a guy
cheats a girl should leave
no
why that's two folks most men just want
to how many people want to keep their
stomach full and such and such
yeah if she's doing that it's fine but
if she's not or she's just always bitter
or getting on this case yeah but not
putting out that's all the man wants so
if if she's like having sex with him
once a week do you think that i think
that's bad that's bad twice a week
every day most of the time when men wake
up okay they're ready to ask okay so
every day if she's having sex with him
every day and he still cheats wow
i don't know
that's interesting i've never seen him
never
in your experience as long as a girl
puts out yeah most men are going to do
this possibly yeah but then you have
those when you first met him when you
met him he might have had a woman you
might have seen it you met him yeah but
then you fell in love or yeah whatever
happens yeah
no that's true like a lot of girls like
think that he'll change for them
no like sweetie you're not special
and what's like your end game out of
this do you like you just want to like
get as many hoes as possible if you want
to get married like what's your end goal
yeah i'm probably going to make like a
music video like or some [ __ ] like
[Music]
because i think there's so many
different facets of life that are
important like finance is something that
a man should have
uh fitness and muscle and everything is
something that a match will handle uh
game and like the ability to be
comfortable and to be able to get women
if you want if he wants to yeah that is
something
it shouldn't be that you're going out
and getting those all the time it's like
do you have the ability to have it or
not like if you're going to battle that
that sort should be hard like completely
so my thing is uh the game thing is just
for me it's more like i just want to be
comfortable and be who i am in my own
skin because i just the reason why other
people don't like you is because you
don't like yourself yeah and you don't
like yourself because you're not doing
things that are not challenging or
making you better yeah so that's why i'm
doing it i'm just trying i'm just
challenging myself and trying to get
guys as the best as i possibly can
socially and everything else when did
you first get into games
uh
like 10 years ago because i was kind of
like a sales background yeah i've always
loved getting better at
my skill set yeah and i saw that like i
didn't have like a
thing i thought i wanted and i was like
i could do the same thing i kind of just
searched this out and figured out how to
get better
like i wasn't like i didn't care that
much about it and i was being nice
genuine but i
we're going to approach women here well
happy i'm going to watch and be
entertained so far it's been decent but
i think day game is where like you learn
the most because you can like hear the
notes
so we'll see we'll see what happens well
i'm going to tell you guys like stuff
but at the same time
you like i promise you it will be 80
times more effective if you do it
yourself without me telling you what to
do there's no problem before so i would
do the same thing but do opposites so
instead of being like
oh am i being too much but when you show
that like am i so you're questioning
whether or not you're okay yeah you
should always know you're fine yeah oh i
knew i was fine every time i was like it
might be like so i would reverse it and
put it under here say look i can't be
kissing like this because like it's
turning me on like you're gonna give me
a moment
[Music]
[Music]
yeah what happens is like they start
dancing more sexy on you yeah more
intense and like
they do
so yeah not every girl is like that but
like some girls yeah i think
[Music]
you think as a guy it's better to go out
in a group of guys in my opinion two
guys just too fast that's illegal
because like
say there's a group of ten girls and
they're two guys
there's two girls that will be one that
kind of separates from their group
and the other girls can educate
themselves two guys is very lethal that
also comes down to like who you're with
so like those two guys they both got to
be stuck they gotta go underneath them
relatively yeah yeah like at least at
least one
so like so you can have one guy carry
the interaction because she likes you so
much yeah the friend will make it work
so like if i'm a girl and i want to be
approached right would you say it's
better to go out with less girls then if
you're talking to all your girls like
together like everyone's like kind of
talking yeah you have your own little
thing going yeah it's a little bit
harder to approach yeah but if you have
like your girls there's eight girls
right here it's just the two of us right
here and yeah walk away it's very easy
for us to come chat with you guys
without having to engage with all eight
of
everybody else right so in a place where
you're just a little bit more
approachable and if you're with your
girls that's fine but don't speak if you
want to get approached like don't be
shown in your table section yeah it's
just like well it's interesting because
i think as a girl like i get approached
the most with two with two yeah yeah
because
and i can't bring hotter girls in my
group like if i have a friend that's
better looking than me like then they'll
approach the friends so i'm like i gotta
find it you're like you know what's
funny is i feel like a lot of times it's
awesome really mental approach the less
the less like uh the kind of scary
lesson
oh you're right i was probably too hot
it was me right like yeah
no no no like literally like i could not
like there's a lot of times where it's
like
this happens to me all the time like
i'll go in the group i'd like
i'll approach a group yeah yeah and i
just engaged like whoever's like like
the nicest yeah it's like sometimes
sometimes like the really hot one will
be like the quiet one yeah so i said
engage anyone who's like talking me
and then my friends were rolling like oh
what up and like they're on it's like
it's like my shaker yeah and like i'm
like okay i'm okay with that like yeah
you know but like that's kind of how it
works like you know just for me when i
approach people when i approach a group
i will i will give the most attention to
whoever is the most fun
oh that's so interesting actually that's
like not as a girl that's not what you
think like as females like i feel like
we think like guys just are going to go
for the hottest girl you know about that
no yeah you know it's funny because like
i'll approach groups oftentimes and
and i can kind of see like who's i can
sense like who's the single one who's
available yeah but whoever's like most
engaging and fun i'll kind of chat with
them yeah sometimes it'll be like the
one who's quiet that's like available
yeah the loud ones and like the most
like the most like uh like ones
that are like let me have a boyfriend
yeah
i don't know why that is shouldn't they
be their like quiet one
no yeah the ones that the ones have
boyfriends they know they're not gonna
get like nothing's gonna come of it
they're not yeah there's no threat it's
just like sales
um sometimes like i'll talk to like a
wife
who's not the decision maker yeah and
should i go okay she's like nice and
says yes but everything oh yeah
i got to talk to my husband yeah how do
you know she wasn't the decision maker
in the beginning
so when somebody is letting
when when they're not giving you
objections when they're not slowing it
down when they're not like asking
serious questions yeah it's because
they're not really considering mine what
are you saying yes yes yes there was
interesting cause when i have a
boyfriend like i like
try to be less like talkative because i
don't want to be like anything that'd be
like disrespectful towards him you know
what i mean it sounds interesting
because like what i would do like is the
opposite of what you're uh yeah like a
lot of that for me it's just it's very
it's
look if the boyfriend is in the venue
it's completely different she will not
talk to you or engage you yeah very very
very very close yeah when i have a
student go talk to a girl who's like
extremely like oh no no no
no really fast yeah
there's a boyfriend in the venue
[Music]
yeah she's gonna be very very close
because that's not natural but most
girls don't do
[Music]
like i think most girls don't want like
like girls aren't direct it's just like
not natural for us to be direct like
yeah just like just to shun somebody
like yeah like ugly but that's usually
like if a boyfriend is watching or he's
very jealous and she has to like slow it
down but like look if the girl's
boyfriend is like in chicago and she's
here in vegas yeah she'll be the
funniest like coolest chick
entertain you all night long at the
night but anyways i can't yeah i can't
come over because i'm working yeah
yeah it's like foundation yeah like they
love it yeah and the thing is like and
like in guys who really want to meet
girls and the one person take them
seriously i i tell them like scream that
out like yeah figure that out that's the
friends like or whatever it is out of
100 girls that have a boyfriend how many
would she i mean
i don't really push that i don't know
what you guys do
i try to be a little bit more yeah i
just
i don't really go for that uh
if i was going for 100 percent of girls
who have boyfriends if i just went for
it every single time
20 would probably shoot out of the book
that's actually what the stats say they
say like 25 percent of girls you might
want to see yeah
and 25 percent of guys too 25
yeah but in the over 250 thousand
dollars it's 50
so that's why i like oh as a guy did the
women will see more
no no it's equal about but if a guy
makes over 250 000 then it ups from 25
chance of cheating
i mean anonymous surveys so like it
could be
but like the that's because like
most guys don't have the option
obviously if more people have the
opportunity to do the wrong thing more
people are going to do it right i just
know from like co-approach like yeah
it's about no it's funny that like you
as like i would say like an expert of
this stuff like would say the same thing
as the like anonymous stats say yeah so
it kind of gives them a little more
credibility you know
because i can see that yeah 24 yeah
i know i know
is there anything that that anyone could
have did better i still figured walk up
to somebody at least like at least like
me in their peripheral
mix so they can really see that you're
there first yeah i think it may have
said like hey like too soon like yeah so
but yeah he did a good job okay
okay we'll keep you guys posted
[Music]
you guys need to know your [ __ ] worth
the group that we had on our last boot
camp like they did not have near the
talent looks or just like everything
that you guys have what you guys
wouldn't take no you're [ __ ] worth
dude i look at jason i'm like dude this
guy looks [ __ ] great like he's in
this club by talking to this girl she
has no idea who he is we can we can look
at like a woman and know that she's old
or [ __ ] or unfit or unhealthy
whatever it is but a guy a girl can't
really perceive that about a dude they
have they pursue it through behavior
jason can roll up and literally be
[ __ ] uh what's the guy from a
billionaire from uh fifty shades who
should be that guy
they don't [ __ ] know he's not
christian great how the [ __ ] do they
know be mysterious
i promise you guys that mr gray is going
to come up ultra confident he's not
going to be mumbling you know so it's
like if if you act like that then
they'll you know they kind of assume
that's who you are like i i think that
this is the one thing like the
self-trust being assured of yourself
knowing that it's just [ __ ] fine a
lot of guys will text like they'll get
in the tech i've got guys that like that
i like coach in the past i'll text me
hey like what should i say about this
the girl i'm like dude [ __ ] trust
yourself it's [ __ ] fine it's good
enough and that's all it has to be it
just has to be good enough and don't
whenever you're like oh like well it's
like i just don't know if it was like
this and like you unsure of yourself
that's when you when you're being unsure
is for it's for children i'm telling you
i watch girls leave the venue in the
club with guy after guy of guys are just
regular [ __ ] dudes but i get again
self trust is everything and and
honestly if i rolled in and i'm like
dude this is [ __ ] great it's going
good you're like oh [ __ ] this is going
good and then all sudden your behavior
is gonna like come off like as if like
you become more confident and she's like
oh yeah she starts liking you more what
changed it's like i reassured your
beliefs in yourself that should have
[ __ ] been there from the get-go yeah
trust yourself to make that decision for
the next step in your set but then also
have the trust in yourself or confidence
to say if i
did something wrong i know myself and i
know i'm smart enough to step back and
do it again and i'll do it right the
next time it's [ __ ] and you're sick
and you just and that's still funny
right it's iterations you like so you
just try it work you step back and try
it again be ready to burn the set down
and calibrate backwards this is one of
the best things i can recommend because
if you're worried about blowing out the
set then you're going to be worried
about everything else not saying what
you want be willing to blow out the
[ __ ] set in other words don't be a
mass opener to open everything like the
check try to
close every set right so the first that
you open try to close that one and go as
far as you can jesse how many times have
you closed the first girl you met did
the first or second one it's like i have
to get picky with my first stop and i'm
like
oh
i'm probably going to close this one so
i have to get thank you let's not
literally i go as far as i can with the
first second night
none of the students have pulled yet but
you know the future could be right we
made it to the beach the beach club
i think we've been here before some
random guy just tried to buy my ticket
to get me in
[Music]
okay i wish
no i appreciate it i have a boyfriend
though i have a boyfriend
my entire life i wish i could have
showed you this little lady was pushing
this like guy
out of the building it was so funny all
right i've been telling the coaches who
to go after
and i told him
in a pink dress
and i think he's getting hurt
all right i've been giving guys girls
all night i just picked two
they're about to go do it all of the
guys i'm walking around
and i'm seeing them flirting a little
bit better they want
we'll see if they bring anyone home i
don't know
but i would say it's a little a little
bit better
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
a mermaid
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
again once again
how many numbers did you get i really
haven't gotten that many numbers tonight
because i wasn't pushing for numbers uh
last night i probably got about 12. and
that was probably out of like 14 sets
how's it going so far tonight a lot of
approaches and a lot more brutal and
become a lot more aggressive because you
are more aggressive
do you work security here okay i have a
question
how many people do you typically kick
out in a day oh it's a lot like five ten
probably more than that it's usually
they usually catch them doing
you know petty drugs or something like
that
or catch up stealing something with
somebody else oh really yeah there's a
variety of reasons fighting glad i did
not put my purse on probably 50. 50. on
a saturday night you know maybe less
tonight i've started shooting here
yeah it's on youtube wow that's wow
well
thanks for the intro
no i'm okay okay i'm actually sober like
believe it or not
i like didn't drink it all
oh look at the coach the coaches pulled
again
are they going home yeah sometimes you
feel some type of way since you like
paid for it and like the last two i
literally just said that i literally
just said that that would make me feel
so tired how much did you guys pay for
this
all right all right
more or less than five
oh my god i need to teach this stuff i'm
going home i have no idea if they're
gonna pull but i have like a flight
pretty early tomorrow it's like two um
i'm coming home from the airport i'm so
tired i literally slept for like three
hours last night and i'm like ran to the
airport that was such a fun and
interesting weekend what did you enjoy
about the boot camp it's kind of an
interesting way for guys to kind of
connect guys just want to connect i
guess basically and one of the ways is
just trying to hit on girls i guess
there was kind of a camaraderie there
there was definitely kind of an
uplifting spirit where it's like hey
we're all here to learn what did you not
like about it you already know this and
i kind of had an issue with one of the
coaches he was frustrating me a lot i
was talking to a girl and things were
going very well and she said hey one sec
i'm gonna take some shots with my
friends so i let her go do that one of
the coaches came up to me he's like why
are you standing all by yourself and i
was like i'm in an interaction right now
like she's just kind of taking her time
she wants to go take shots with her
friends and so the coach then just kind
of started pushing the idea of like hey
go ask for a kiss right now go ask for a
kiss right now i'm like dude that's no
that's weird she already walked away and
she's already with her friends so if i
just go over there and start like trying
to pull her in like that's just weird
and it's gonna ruin the interaction no
go do it go do it and i was like i know
you're wrong about this but i will do it
just for your sake so i went ahead and
did it and then she didn't talk to me
the rest of the night just kind of
proved my point of like hey dude like
there is there's time to put pressure
and then there's time to just kind of
like hey just let her go you just didn't
like how pushy he was yeah it was
ridiculously pushy i felt like he kind
of treated you like you were a beginner
like you know what i mean like he didn't
really treat you because i would say
you're definitely like not a beginner
when it comes to this stuff so when i
was like looking back on the camp the
way i looked back on it was the camp
would be best for someone that's just
starting would you agree with that yes
kind of it just depends on the type of
person that's where i say for the most
part i would never really recommend this
type of camp for
anyone mainly because of the cost
involved uh it's how what was the actual
cost for the i think it's around 5000.
for three days yeah to me that's just
kind of ridiculous just pick a friend
someone who maybe is kind of confident
and just say and even if they're not
even really your friend just pitch them
100 bucks say i'll buy your drinks for
the night but i want you to push me out
of my comfort zone so that i go and talk
to these women that there were a couple
coaches that were actually pretty
helpful that do
know how to do this i do not promote
sleeping with hundreds of women i think
there are long-term consequences however
i do think the skills learned at these
boot camps can help men get in the door
there are a lot of conversations i had
with the guys that were like off camera
and it was really interesting to hear
from guys that basically can sleep with
whoever they want that take home double
digit girls in a month and i asked a lot
of these guys do you guys plan on
settling down at some point or do you
just want to do this forever and it was
really interesting to hear that most of
the guys did want to settle down and
what is even more interesting is most of
them wanted a girl with a particularly
low body count i also talked to the guys
about the difference between sexual
attention and relationship attention and
how women don't know the difference they
all agreed that they would sleep with
one type of woman that they would never
ever be in a relationship with another
interesting thing was some of the guys
actually specifically stay off of social
media so the girls that they are talking
to cannot find each other usually you
would think if a guy has no social media
that's a green flag
what
so ladies guys will use you at practice
and some girls want to be used and they
want to use them so if they want to do
what they're going to do who am i to
stop them one thing i should have asked
was about stds because they gotta they
have to have contracted something do i
think that the bootcamp was helpful uh
yes i do think it was helpful um i try
to be as open and honest about this
experience as i can i would guess that
john's online course is probably more
helpful than a three-day bootcamp you
have to remember that this is three days
you are not gonna get a hundred percent
better at a skill in three days you
might get ten to twenty percent better
and if that's worth the money to you so
be it one of the criticisms i did have
of the conference is that if i paid
thousands of dollars for three days i
would be ticked off if one of my
instructors left to go home with a girl
i understand that maybe they're just
showing that they are experienced and
can get women but if you're an
instructor at that point like aren't you
there to teach i would love to see in
pick up a boot camp that's more for
beginners and more for intermediates
because i felt like this boot camp was
tailored more for beginners and people
that are just getting started and i do
think at times that maybe held back some
of the more intermediate guys one thing
i learned from the conference is that
getting laid as a guy is a lot harder
than i thought being at the conference
like it kind of put me into the guy's
perspective because clearly i'm trying
to help them talk to women and make
women feel comfortable whatever and it
just blew my mind how many girls the
guys would have to approach in order to
become successful with one even the
relatively like more conventionally
attractive guys had to approach a lot of
girls before they could get one guys i'm
in bed editing this video um see and i
realized i never made an outro so this
is me telling you guys don't forget to
like comment subscribe let me know in
the comments if you like these type of
videos and let me know what i should
research next thanks guys